[Music]
you
you
[Music]
to starting your suit needs regulation
[Music]
vital signs critical
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
time time
I'm a tree
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
final sack
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Music]
watch out
so question new operator
Trillian right here Oh medical consult
razorfish please stand clear about you
diagnosing look like you had a rough day
I'll have you feeling oh don't forget to
complete a patient questionnaire your
feedback will be invaluable
or to me
[Music]
- Maya faked diagnosing you're suffering
from radiation poisoning intervention
this won't take long
all done please fill out a patient
experience questionnaire so I can serve
you better next time
[Music]
[Applause]
gently in silence optical
[Music]
you
hello good to see you again doctor you
diffusion for diagnosing oh my radiation
syndrome they're all better please fill
out a patient experience questionnaire
so I can serve you better next time
[Music]
sincerity
[Music]
good work I was worried the drive might
have been damaged you can use TVO's
workstation to download the fabrication
plan then we can reconstruct your arming
key welcome maybe I can help you
operator
[Applause]
Morgan Alex has you boxed in look
there's nothing I can do about the
lockdown from out here but I promised
I'd help you so listen deep storage was
built with a series of data fault
modules that can be jettisoned from the
station
it's a redundant backup system that's
your way out
look at my workstation again I'm
exposing your utility that'll open up
one of the vaults once you're in look
for a manual release then your asses
space junk like me and if you manage to
get back inside
remember you owe me Joel the son of a
[ __ ] who hurt Abbi
all right swear to god I'll haunt you
Oh
you
oh gee fellas are here how to help you I
need you to report to this source and it
seeks to reactivate the tracker on grant
Lockwood HR deactivated
you
gravity detective you are
Morgan Morgan mrs. G fellas all the
Arabs on Talos are sealed but is it an
opening at the cargo bay you could use I
think you can get back inside the
station here
you
[Music]
[Music]
mu I find you outside your prison maybe
trying to escape likely not safe out
there well you know this you have
headaches see things it is not Seaver
not hallucinations horizon is coming
cutting through space if we're still
here when I arrived it screams so loud
we hear it in our head there is still
far away but it is coming close it will
eat your prison every person on board
and it will still be hungry where will
their goal next I wonder I see you back
in your prison so mu
[Music]
stupid IO Equis
I'm broadcasting to all contacts in
proximity please whoever is RT listen to
me oxygen is low and I have no spacesuit
an accident in cargo bay force me to
seal myself inside this container but I
have no way to dock with the station
from here
wait wait what are you doing stop
stop down you stone
[Music]
Morgan Morgan mrs. Chi fellas up the
Arabs on Talos are sealed but is it been
opening and the cargo bay you could use
I think you can get back inside the
station here
list of the entire equation and
broadcasting to all contacts in
proximity please whoever is out there
listen to me oxygen is low and I have no
spacesuit an accident in cargo bay force
me to seal myself inside this container
but I have no way to dock with the
station from here
a Mew I find you outside your prison may
be trying to escape my clean block safe
out there for you notice you have
headaches see things it is not Seaver
not hallucinations a horizon is coming
cutting through space before I still
hear when it arrives it screams so loud
we sure you know add there is still far
away but it is coming closer it will eat
your prison every person on board and it
will still be hungry where will their
goal next I wonder I see you back in
your prison soon and you
hello oh my is someone out there can you
hear me it's dr. he gray from the neuro
Madhavi
please I'm trapped I need assistance
I'm running out of air here it's running
soon I need your help you can get back
to the cargo bay please whatever you do
don't open the door I don't have a
helmet
most code I'm embarrassed to say I do
not know it
here is Pierce I can hear you quite well
I assure you
hello oh mercy last you someone out
there can you hear me
it's doctor away from the neuroma
division please unclutch I need
assistance I'm running out of air please
I have no spacesuit it is somewhere to
top the container with a cargo bay I see
you Morgan we've locked down the cargo
bay we're safe for the moment it will be
a trick to get inside there's not an
airlock anymore that explosion took care
of that maybe you can do something with
the shipping containers
you
pothinus atmosphere conditions
as a response here conditions
a Mew I find you outside your prison
maybe trying to escape like me not safe
out there well you know this you have
headaches
it is not Seaver not hallucinations a
horizon is coming
cutting through space if we're still
here when it arrives it screams so loud
we hear you know how it feels far away
but it is coming close it will eat your
prison every person of board and it will
still be hungry
where will they go next I wonder I see
you back in your prison so mu I see you
Morgan
we've locked down the cargo bay we're
safe for the moment it will be a trick
to get inside there's not an airlock
anymore that explosion took care of that
maybe you can do something with the
shipping containers
Oh at last I thought that crate would be
my coffee even with spare air of Talos
laced with faint into nicotine and
antibacterials oh he's like spring yeah
my thanks talk to you but I thought well
you're no longer running the memory
hamster wheel I see I hope you're coming
in after me would be good to see a
familiar face and transmitting the code
to the crate I was in found out hurried
way you worked in the simulation lab and
in psychotronics he might be helpful but
he's unlikely to approve of your mission
despite everything he suffered though I
will note he's always admired you and
Alex quite a bit
you
you
I got a bad feeling
dr. yu Morgan up here officer cool if we
can't open the main door or our friends
are going to pour through get up to the
catwalk we'll get you in I got a bad
feeling
dr. u Morgan up here officer cool if we
can't open the main door or our friends
are going to pour through get up to the
catwalk we'll get you inside
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Morgan I thought I don't know what I
thought it's good to see you
is Transtar mounting a rescue operation
I was in fuel storage when when the fire
broke out and everyone began running but
they weren't running from the fire it
was these shapes
I had contained the fire I was trying to
reach the power supply when al officer
Rose came and guns not I'm glad he did I
didn't know what was going on or
anything about those things everyone I
worked with they're dead aren't they
thank you I wonder if what if the
creatures caused the explosion and fuel
storage are the intelligence y equation
I heard all the escape pods
malfunctioned in the head of neuro all
of them how is that it but well now
might be best yeah I'm sure you could
make better use of it
microgravity upsets Mike with Adriana I
need to steady myself after the slow
roll at the crate I could feel it
turning you know my stomach along with
it closest I've ever come to vertical
and claustrophobia must be a neuro mode
that could cure that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if only I could have put out the fire
its contained but I could have done more
Herr doctor Igor was floating in a cargo
crate outside the ship
maybe seder he might have survived
longer than any of us
captain Eleazar will want to speak to
you we only recently learned you were
still on the station dr. eagle a is
blessed it was fortunate you came along
when you did
I'm going to sick of waiting for them to
come to us
God watching those things move makes me
sick what is it doing oh my god did it I
think I'm gonna be sick we just made
another one of those things like it like
you pulled it right out of the knocks
course yeah course maybe I don't know
maybe it saved him it could still be
inna does it look like it sing promise
me you'll kill me if I ever end up like
that
Sarah we'll get us out of this she got
us this far
we're safe in here but now I'm going to
check the perimeter
don't know if Wiggy doctor egg way is
lucky to be here or not
vitamins safer in his crate
if you find a way out of here take dr.
agree with you maybe he can be of some
help elsewhere so you came all this way
only to get back into Kalos only way in
is through the door to cargo baby which
is filled with those creatures that your
brother insisted couldn't escape
confinement kind of like you I'm the
only one with the code it's yours if you
can help us secure the firepower we
should have had when assigned here the
Eradicator turrets fabrication plan then
my men told me power has been restored
to the fabricator that was you wasn't it
I was quick to underestimate you doctor
that means all we need is the turrets
fabricated plan there's one in the safe
in the Security office but the hull
breach puts it out of my reach stay if
you have a suit and are up for another
walk we could really use the additional
firepower look I don't know what you're
planning Morgan but just remember the
only thing that matters is how you treat
the people that are still alive
we're not going anywhere but that
doesn't mean we don't have places to be
we need real service not to give way
figures he'd survive dumb luck I suppose
the question new operator
Transtar pyramid for a 9:04 class
operator wreckage and applause please
stand clear about mature welcome maybe I
can help you there must be a way to get
some torts online
hello these Transtar PPN eight pistols
are mostly for you know they don't do
much again before we will eradicate a
turn I don't understand but it's just a
saying it it means that are you doing
okay
oh I am off the road ow
thank you
Caterina it's been so long since I see
you
well it feels like I think that it's a
compliment
the plans could help but even if we had
the e8e set having real guns would have
been better
nothing will get past me doctor you
[Applause]
available
good you again doctor you
any luck with those turrets
I see you made use of the medical
operator that thing has saved us
repeatedly
any luck with the Leafs
if only I had reached the power supply
in time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
attention incoming shipments from earth
have been temporarily delayed personnel
are directed to clear up fast logs
deliveries until notified by a
supervisor
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we won can I'm still breathing we're
still breathing I don't I don't give
this back that was careless opening the
door like that we locked ourselves in
because it wasn't safe what were you
thinking sir opening the main door all
the other deaths not enough for you more
where that came from those were not the
last of the enemy area secured if more
come we will be ready we did a check of
all League ways equipment all genuine no
organic matter is clean
[Music]
I'll make sure Transtar earth knows what
you did putting us at risk like that
watching the main door wasn't sure how
that would play out but I like how it
did
no movement room secure now that we are
secure here we can hold out indefinitely
if you send other survivors here I will
protect them keep our stunts like the
door again and the next door you open
will be the airlock
stack it you're dropping the tree
[Music]
[Music]